hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to monstrum now we have
a plan things did not go very well for
us in the last episode not my fault at
all not even close to my fault you may
think it was my fault but it was this
damn cursing ship that dust hold my soul
hostage and present itself to the
monster I need to learn to shut up when
I need to shut up either way what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go forward and I'm
gonna get the components to get the life
raft in order because if I can get the
life raft in order and less like the
pieces of the other escape methods
present themselves to me I think I'm
gonna be able to actually get off of
this boat and survive now I don't know
if there are multiple options for
endings depending on which route you go
however that's not my worry right now I
only care about what I said gotta be
flickering like that I only care about
getting this done and getting it done
like right now oh god that is a security
camera okay so I'm gonna fast forward a
bit because I'm it's gonna take a lot of
hunting and quite a bit BRB did he come
from where did he go where did he come
from cotton-eye Joe it's bouncing it's
so exciting for me to find it
yes mr. Peter pump I'm gonna get you
over to somewhere and then pump you bub
okay I don't have a lot of time to make
really creepy jokes mister jumpy pump
how about we just get the hell out of
here
oh [ __ ] why don't you throw him don't
don't don't
dude that's right thank you okay I got
the pump the monster wants me to pump
[ __ ] was that I need to get out of here
okay this is bad this is about as bad as
a situation begin I am stuck I don't
like this this is actually quite creepy
actually I'm quite disturbed what's
going on here but it's good no it's good
it's all good monstrosity want to come
listen and dance I suppose is somehow
supposed to make me feel better I'm a
horrible horrible life out of old I am
not having that thing I should be
worried about worried about a lot of
things in life I don't much appreciate
these noises at you happening I don't
like this game my least-favorite came to
play there's a whole lot of nothing
everybody celebrate nothing bad happened
and I finally got a goddamn glow stick I
can get that music out that was probably
not good for me to just be blasting
music on a ship alone that's quiet oh
it's so quiet I'm sure no one will care
[Music]
Journal updated pull this back okay I'm
gonna assemble this bastard
I'm missing what am I missing seal the
tears inflate the raft palm pump it up I
need to seal it seal it up
seal good okay now I pump it up just
once good enough you know I thought
maybe not maybe a little more okay
just a little more oh okay it's got a
tent now to sing it some smooth jazz
that feel good for you mr. roffe's tea
you're gonna get to read to safety I
gotta find a chain or something
oh my way to find it ain't no one gonna
stop me from Jane this game is [ __ ]
with me man jumping at ghosts I've been
heard the big guy in a long time
and that kind of worries me whoa oh this
God I had to say one damn thing about
you big man god damn it okay so I found
this sub maroon hopefully this means I
can solve its like maybe there's a chain
holding it up or something and I can
drop it in favor of the raft because
definitely definitely a raft would be a
better option than a goddamn whatever oh
hey big guy I'm gonna win oh my goodness
Oh
don't pursue miss dickbag okay so now I
just have to get back to this before
retain this bull be done and I can get
off this ship dammit
hahaha you guys cared for me okay what
do i do where do I do it how do I do
this
do it do it do it do it do it do it do
it dammit
Dewey Decimal System do it dammit that's
not what I want it oh oh is it good now
[Music]
don't use the fire extinguisher on it
you dingus aren't I supposed to be on
that
[Music]
[Applause]
tap okay escape the ship okay I can do
that I can do that god dammit I fell and
broke my ankles I couldn't crawl to the
frickin boat oh why do they jump off oh
I'm gonna be sick clothes I [ __ ] it up
I [ __ ] it up oh such an idiot oh
you're all screaming at me why did I
jump
Oh ruin everything
god damn the biggest city ever fudge I
hate life right now because I have to
start over again for me hey guess what
cameraman why just call me the big red
blue Evie's already happened with me a
new one comedian
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
are you kidding me there was another
[ __ ] monster on the ship the whole
goddamn time I got a headache
okay handle this what the [ __ ] how is
there another goddamn monster on the
goddamn ship that's some nasty music you
got going on there what does this get
cranked into hard mode extreme meet him
to meet him I don't see him I want big
red again want big red to come on by I
want to give him me big old hug no okay
mission parameters are still the same
I'm trying to get to the life raft I
just can't frickin believe that not only
did I screw up so badly that I jumped
and sprained my ankle what oh he came
through the fence but not only it was a
big dumb doof and wasn't able to control
my fall but also now I have to deal with
the new monster that I really really
really really really really really never
wanted me to ever again what's up [ __ ] I
just turned on my music for a little
warmth
I don't see anything
is it not following low stick yay maybe
I can finally get somewhere hey hey I'll
finally be able to see no no no no no no
no no no no we come from Billy boo
wait come from Billy Baba is about horn
me about horn whoo - whoo Jesus uses
walking calmly towards me
right making weird noises God why do I
hear it Nazi
[Music]
okay I honestly don't know when it
crawled up to me I don't know who's just
because I was using the the little glow
stick there or if it was because my
monitor is so dark or I couldn't see
anything in the game I don't know if you
guys could either it was just there like
suddenly I heard it crawling and I saw
it I was trying to get a good eye for it
because the other big guy here's a
freaking flashlight on his forehead god
damn it what the [ __ ] god damn it I was
that close to winning and I [ __ ] it
all up and then I met a new monster
didn't know there even was one god damn
it I was so close okay so I you knew
that again probably better with big red
than whatever the deuce that was but
either way that is still monstrum I need
one more episode to beat this because
I've been playing for about 45 minutes
now so thank you all so much for
watching let me know what you think of
the comments below if you're playing
this game for yourself are there
alternate endings for ending on a
certain way like escaping via life
rafter or submarine or helicopter like
what does it all mean
thank you again so let me know who the
government oh man and as always I will
see you in the next video
gonna do
[Music]